I'm sorry darling I just can't hear you
over the loud color of your cheap pants
I know you think your mom is this
heartless in our sophistic monster or
worse
some days I do too but when you get past
that there is
firing person in there you better get us
a quote that will offend virtually
everyone I have a meeting with the board
today at lunch so cancel sushi with my
mother oh and cancel my therapist I
won't be needing it if I'm not having
lunch with my mother
got it miss grant this came through
their private courier if you keep me
safe from prying eyes why didn't you
open it it could be anthrax I never
realized how absurd you look in that
ridiculous outfit blue yellow and red
it's like a color wheel threw up I've
handled Putin
and Taylor Swift this is Adam I think
I'll take it from here
Tweedledee staff meeting everyone in my
office stacked with a side of ASAP it's
not that I don't see your frown it's
just that I don't care enough to ask why
it's there now get out of my office and
never come back
you